you know t-shirt it's great to see you
again we just spent a little time down
the Oval Office and uh we just finished
an excellent meeting so uh
so now we can enjoy a little bit of a
celebration when I went over to Ireland
I was it was a it was a great A great
experience I'd been to Ireland any time
but not to actually look up to find my
actual family members and there are so
many and they actually weren't in jail
they were all but all kidding aside I
met the Lewis and the Finnegans and all
of the folks who were related to spent
six days there and uh one of the things
that and the and the in the Finnegans
are from County Laos and they're still
if you go to County louth there's still
a place called Finnegan's Pub which is a
Reverend that's related to my my family
now I'm the only Irish we've ever met
though that's never had a drink so I'm
okay
I'm really not Irish
but look look as many of you know I like
all of you take pride in my Irish
ancestry and uh as long as I can
remember it's been it's been a part of
my soul